et eux dénoncent l'état d'urgence
sanitaire qui à leurs yeux je cite
piétine arbitrairement les libertés de
chacun il a été validé en tout cas par
le conseil constitutionnel jusqu'au 10
juillet des avocats se sont rassemblés
en fin d'après-midi place vendôme et se
sont regroupés façon ministère de la
justice pour exprimer leur colère sur
ces images on peut voir une dizaine
d'avocats scandant des slogans pancartes
et fumigènes dans les mains ou il
réclame donc le rétablissement de l'état
de droit en france peut plus gérer la
crise sanitaire et ados gens quand il y
avait un plan je dirais d'arrêt total de
toutes les juridictions
hormis je dirais les juridictions
pénales est encore dans des conditions
catastrophiques on disait pour les
activités simplement essentiel
donc en fait rien n'a marché et dans les
juridictions pénales
il y avait des problèmes donc tous
concernés des mesures de 12,5 et bien
c'était soit des individus procédure
sans autre sans audience sans débat sans
avocat est en fait depuis 17 ans 93 et
dresser la première fois vous en fait on
pouvait prolonger la m sont provisoires
sans un juge rémois